the corrupt politicians and their  special interests have ruled over this  country for a very long time  today is our Independence Day between  strong steady leadership or a loose  canon real change also means restoring  honesty to our government so the first  thing we should do let's get rid of  Hilary okay that's there is no reason my  friends why America's best days are not  ahead of us I know my people  you'll get up after about two hours  you'll vote and you'll go to work  I know my Michigan people it's not just  my name or Donald Trump's name on the  ballot it's the kind of country we want  it's every issue  let's win thank you  you